M it's
God it's
God this gentleman is going to he tends
to take over the room and he's going to
dictate who speaks and who doesn't speak
is your platform open for Muslims and
non- Muslims to speak or only I came I
came here for the host so but but I'm
asking the host do you permit us to
speak as well we we want want to chime
of course you're going to you're going
to Le the live but he's going that some
people can't speak
I come here I'm not speaking to you I'm
asking the hor if I have a guest that
just wants to speak to me then that's
that's the way it should be you know
okay but can I chime in if if I if I you
know get I would only like to speak to
the host I'm not talking to you why you
scared well I don't talk to trolls
that's all well you're the troll you're
the biggest troll we'll see who's the
troll go ahead leave it yeah leave it
thanks for thanks for bringing me up um
so my my name is Ay nice to meet you man
so it says to to learn about Islam or
challenge it I have a I have a specific
challenge I'm a
Christian and um so obviously uh being a
Christian I follow the Bible so what the
Quran says uh about the Bible or the
previous scriptures is important to me
and it talks about how um obviously one
of the big claims is that we can find
Muhammad mentioned in the Torah and the
injil it's chapter 7 verse
157 um it talks about how Jesus
mentioned someone named AIT to come
after him so where would you point to to
show that I guess Muhammad is mentioned
by Jesus in the
ngel okay so first and foremost chapter
one chapter 61 verse 6 when it says
about telling of a man to come up in
name Ahmed this doesn't make any
reference to any Scripture it simply
states that Isam has made this statement
whether it was part of the inil or not
it is not mentioned the um in the verse
so we cannot
assert that this is um this is something
that was from the okay what was the
other sorry what was the other thing you
saw the other one was 7157 how it talks
about this is in reference this is in
reference to the people at the time so
this is this verse is revealed in
historical context and in some aspects
so for example the reason why some
Muslims use verses like Deuteronomy 1818
or Isaiah 42 is because of this
historical context so what happened is
in the time of
theam there were certain Jews that were
speaking about the prophet disp upon him
and affirming that he was a
prophet and they would use um verses now
the verses we the verses from the Torah
that we have recorded in our tradition
they are not verbatim first and foremost
we have to understand they are not
verbatim
to Deuteronomy 18 or Isaiah 42 they're
not at all
secondly the reason why Muslims say that
is because they say this is the closest
in the in the current versions of the
Torah um that we find it okay so that's
essentially what is being said so it's
leveled in a it's put in a historical
context okay um yeah all right so it's
interesting you so you're taking the
angle when when Jesus mentions AET to
come after him you're saying oh well it
doesn't say that he said this in a
particular scripture so we can't assert
that and so okay my my question would be
with that then um because you would
agree that this would be a revelation
that Jesus is is giving right so would
would Jesus be giv Revelation that's not
in the
NGO yes and how do you know that
because the prophet because Allah
subhana tala has revealed um things to
be in scripture and outside of scripture
and every single uh Prophet was sent as
a Warner as well so if you look in
chapter 16 of the Quran um can't
remember the verse but Allah says about
The Messengers that they came to deliver
the message but to be Warners as well
right so they would speak the things
that were Revelation outside of the
scripture so for example with Moses mes
we know collectively as Jews Christians
and Muslims that Moses came with two
aspects of the Torah the scripture and
the oral tradition this is something
that we all believe in so is the oral
tradition part of the Torah no it's not
it's separate to it it is not recited as
scripture so this is how we know okay so
you're saying it's the same thing with
Jesus that he would have come with an
oral tradition that was not necessarily
scripture yeah this is a possibility
like I said I will not affirm nor deny
anything because the verse is not uh
making any uh positive statement on the
statement itself whether it's part of
the scripture or um you know separate
from so so it wouldn't be it wouldn't be
off if someone did take this as it being
part of the scripture and someone
wouldn't be off if they didn't take this
as part of the scripture but more so an
oral like no one would be necessarily
right or wrong either way
uh if anyone takes a positive stance on
either they would be wrong because then
they make because then they would make
um a a positive statement on something
that's not you know explicitly said
gotcha I got you I understand what
you're saying so then uh what about the
NG then what would they uh where would
they have found him mentioned in the
ngel
Muhammad so again it's the Sim same
thing with the um with the Torah right
there will be certain verses okay that
allude to him so again Muslims look at
the paraclet for example
um the verses regarding that and I know
the Christian arguments about it and
everything that's not the point we're
having so there are certain uh verses or
certain statements not necessarily that
are in your current gospels or new
testament well actually gospel because
the New Testament wouldn't count as the
angile in its entirety
um and and that's how and that's how
they would uh find those verses so again
do you think that that those are valid
places to go to like to go to the
paraclet passages you think those are
valid for them to point to and say hey
this is actually describing
Muhammad um see it's a it's a tough one
right because there is if you look if
you look at it solitarily so there are
four passages with with reference to the
paraclet
they're all contradictory right because
some of them say that Jesus will send
the paraclet some of them say the father
will send the paraclet in my name one of
them acknowledges it to be the Holy
Spirit someone and other says simply the
spirit of Truth so for Christians and
Muslims to harmonize those in into the
context that they believe it means is a
difficult one so me personally my my
criteria or my need to evidence the
prophet sallallahu alhi wasallam from
the previous scripture it's not for me
you know it is for those who take those
scriptures
as um authoritative okay so I what I
would say is I because I don't I
wouldn't say that it's it's
contradictory I think that if you take
it all what is said about the paraclet
in those passages you can see that um
putting it all together both both Jesus
and the father send the Holy Spirit who
is the spirit of Truth so I I think that
that's a pretty consistent
you know theme concerning him I'll tell
you why it's not because for example
Jesus says about the paraclete that he
cannot go he cannot come until he goes
yeah now we know that the Holy Spirit
was present with Jesus and the disciples
at the time so the idea of the Holy
Spirit coming only after he goes it
doesn't it doesn't work well no because
uh that would mean that the Holy Spirit
leaves with him when he left and then is
being sent back and then also in this in
this instance it's not just that well it
is because if he's if he's there if he's
there with them one it it says that he's
there with them but Jesus says but then
he will be in you so he's there but he's
not indwelling them yet so when Jesus
sends him back this time he'll be
actually indwelling the Believers no
this is actually this is your insertion
no that's what it says no okay I know
the I know I know the text very well
okay
so and I know that there is nowhere
where it says that the holy spirit is
going to go okay there's some people
insulting the messenger in the comments
can you make more mods make Salam you
see Salam Salam can you comment can you
make Salam
mod on this guy lightning Darkness he's
got usual fans that are filthy but
uh Dean the one who just commented the
guy with the hello he just said
hello just made him Mar I'm not I'm not
a moderator so your fans are comfortable
I'm not I'm not going to mute anybody
but dog V you could look at the comments
they're they're
blessing look if if the if the people in
the comments are followers of ay and
they are making those comments then it
says two things it says about who Avery
is and it says about who his followers
are doesn't say anything about us it was
it wasn't that long ago when he had
somebody on his platform are we able to
the conversation guys or like what what
are we what are we doing can we can we
go ahead and continue the conversation I
don't know why I don't even understand
why I was I said that why does that
bother you I'm just asking host host are
we able to continue the conversation
host why are you silencing me I'm asking
question you condemned I'm only here
talking to you I'm not here to talk to
any troll can get can I get my I'll go
back I'll go back so can we can we
continue our conversation before
condemnation do you condemn do you
condemn David on your chn we continue
our conversation host yes will you
condemn okay so I'm not responding to
anybody except the host here you condemn
you condemn that
behavior come on thank you so
much so
so so with regards to the verses yes so
when in it says that the holy spirit is
there with them Jesus is going to go
away so the holy spirit's also going to
go away too but Jesus says in the future
that the holy spirit will be in them it
literally does
it doesn't say that yes it does it says
he's with them right as you saw it site
the verse cite the verse where he says
that the holy spirit will go with Jesus
and then come back wait hold on wait
wait so it has to it has to say those
words
verbatim you said no you said that's
what he says yeah I said it says that
it's with them uh the holy spirit is
with them and then will soon be in them
when Jesus sends
him so so if we're putting two and two
together the holy spirit is there
resting on Jesus so be by by virtue of
that they're in the presence of the Holy
Spirit and then as
Jesus on moment if if Jesus if the holy
spirit's resting on Jesus and then Jesus
is leaving and says that he's going to
send the Holy Spirit to the apostles
that put two and two together that means
that the Holy Spirit leaves with Jesus
until he is sent down back to the
apostles that is not the text don't even
allude to that okay so how all break
break down how it doesn't how what I
just said doesn't allude to him being
him leaving with Jesus and then being
sent
back okay so let's actually look at the
text all right right John John 1417 John
1415 and 16 right there are four
different text of this okay yeah I'm
talking about the specific verses that
I'm talking about John 14 verse1 17 bro
stop
panicking
right um if you love keep my
Commandments and I will ask the father
and he will give you another ADV to help
you and be with you forever the spirit
of Truth the world cannot accept him
because he neither sees him nor knows
him but you know him right now this is
already your problem for he lives with
you and and will be in you I will not
leave you as orphans I will come to you
before long the world will not see me
anymore but you will see me because I
live you will also
live okay and it and it carries on yeah
it carries on so verse 177 was the was
the verse that we we were talking about
so how so how's yeah go I'm sorry go
ahead okay so now read it like I said we
got read it in the context of the other
two the other two chapters John verse 15
sorry John 15
yeah so John 15 he says that he is going
to send the spirit from the father who
proceedes from the father second second
let me find the that's all right so when
yeah when the verse 26 when The Advocate
comes I will sent to you from the father
father the spirit of Truth who goes out
from the father he will testify about me
okay yeah now if
he and you must also testify for you has
been with me from the beginning and then
16 I think this verse seven yeah y but
very cly I'll tell you it is for you
good that I am going away unless unless
I go away The Advocate will not come to
you exactly yes right so the thing is
there is a contradiction between John 14
and John um 16 when you talk about I'll
tell you what I'll tell you how the idea
that he's already so it first and
foremost you have a problem in John 14
because it says the world doesn't know
him uh because it neither sees him nor
knows him but you know him which is
weird because how can they know him when
the world doesn't because they're not
part of the world if you read John 17
Jesus says I'm praying for these that
you have given me not for the world so
they're separate from the world no they
are not yes they
are no they're they're not part of the
world bro I just gave you a verse in a
reference where Jesus literally says
they're not part of the
world so referring to the world is
referring to those who are not following
Christ they're not following Jesus
they're not they're not can you do stop
cutting into the conversation please so
when he's talking about those who are
talking about the world he's talking
about those who do not follow Christ
those who are not Believers okay and so
that's what he says the world cannot see
see uh him but or or doesn't know him
but you know him because they're not of
the world and even Romans talks about
this where Paul says we are in the world
we're not but but be not of the world so
okay so you just contradicted yourself
because talking about what
off the world there's a difference in
terms
so I'm very careful wording
okay so it says but you know him for he
lives with you and will be in you so
first and
foremost the Holy Spirit was not with
them because it was only given to them
in in um John 17 and then later later
later again in the uh you know Acts of
the Apostles
or in
Pentecost so first and foremost they
weren't he wasn't with the Holy Spirit
wasn't with them or in them at the time
because it was bring into them later on
wait wait wait time out pause there for
pause there Muhammad so you just
mentioned how the Holy Spirit on the
before the day of Pentecost which is you
know Jesus left so he's gone and so the
Holy Spirit isn't there with them
anymore and then is sent down on the day
of Pentecost you just mentioned that
this is actually going with my point
because here when it talks about hold on
just a second the holy spirit is you you
agree that the holy spirit is resting on
Jesus
correct resting on Jesus yes that the
holy spirit is indwelling Jesus it's on
Jesus right when he got baptized the
Holy Spirit descended on him like a dove
right okay okay so the holy spirit is on
Jesus it's in Jesus wherever Jesus is
that's where the holy spirit is so with
that being said if they are with Jesus
if they're in the presence of Jesus they
are also in the presence of the holy
spirit so that's why Jesus can say for
he is with you now you know him and he's
with you but will in the future see he's
not in you yet but will in the future be
in you so when Jesus sends him and when
he sends him he's going to be in the
Believers not just in the presence of
them so it's not a contradiction well
I'll tell you why I'll tell you why
because you didn't pay attention to what
I was saying in them he was prior to
Pentecost he breathed in the Holy Spirit
to them in John 17 that's what I said
okay so it doesn't actually work because
he because like I said in contradicts uh
chapter 16 where he mentions
that unless Jesus goes hold on sorry I'm
sorry host do you do you do you see the
guest under me this is why I'm not
talking to him because he's posting
pictures he's just here to troll he's
not even here for a serious conversation
no because it's he's just he's just here
to troll and to distract are you
offended you mind just you allowed a guy
to getting rid of this dude or like what
what is going on you allowed somebody to
rip the Quran like this this just show
this just shows the cowardice the
cowardice of you guys man you guys are
here to just
troll first and foremost Avery not you
Muhammad not you you you've been kind
and polite you've been respectful I'm
talking about I'm talking about and
others like him that's what I'm talking
about not you you allow David wood on
your channel to go ahead I'm just I'm
just saying he's he's going to start
something he's gonna try to derail this
just let you just letting you know who
you have on the
panel but go ahead so so so you said I
wasn't you said I didn't hear your point
M
so chapter
17 right the Holy Spirit chapter
17 if I'm not
mistaken
um do you mean Chapter 14 verse 17 no
I'm not talking about that uh let me
see no prior to Pentecost um he gives
them the uh the um
[Music]
okay hold on a second I'm getting a lot
of messages about your desecration of
the Quran um I didn't do anything so
that's anyway people just people are
just here trying to people are trying to
derail the conversation this is what
happens man when we're having a good
conversation the some of the people they
don't like this and they try to derail
the conversation
religion people don't the thing is I
don't know why people sending me
messages I'm already quite aware of who
you are
MH yeah it's okay guys let him get cook
he's already been game so are you so so
what verse are you referring to maybe I
can
help are you talking about where Jesus
blows the Holy Spirit on there yeah I
think that's John um
20 John
20 might be 20
yes it
is yeah right so again so this is why he
is among them right so until he goes
right like I said until he goes um so he
makes it very clear unless I go the Holy
Spirit won't come but he is breathing
the Holy Spirit into them in John 20 um
which is obviously not what the verse
says now secondly in terms of different
interpretations of the of the uh the
term paricle
okay it is also it can be Al it can also
be used to refer to other human
beings I agree depends on the
context well and this is this is where
the two arguments come in this is where
the clash of the Christians and the
Muslims come on how you identify the
term paracle does it refer to the Holy
Spirit Muslims does
yeah according to you according to the
Muslims it doesn't because for example
the the issues within the three um the
three passages regarding the paraclet
how it contradicts okay and um in in
multiple ways I
do
um but you know I'm not going to go into
the details of the three passages I'm
just what I'm doing is to go back on
your previous point is to explain to you
that I would not rely on on these but if
if a Muslim was to
um explain to you from your scripture
from the New Testament perspective
they'll go to the parle from
your Deuteronomy and Isaiah you know
sons of Solomon yes so just to give a to
give a little response here in John 20
Jesus is preparing them to receive the
Holy Spirit that's why he says he blows
into them and says receive the Holy
Spirit and tells them what will happen
um but then tells them not to leave
right um until power has come down this
is why on Pentecost we see the their
actual receiving of the Holy Spirit um
so this is a preparation that he's doing
none of this is in contrad everything is
consistent there's no there's no a and
non a you know there's no contradiction
here if you again seeing the
harmonization we see that the holy
spirit is sent by uh Jesus from the
father uh um in his name in the in the
Name of Christ and that the disciples
are acquainted with him in in his
presence they know him because they know
Jesus and his works his miracles and
then soon we'll be also just like Jesus
was indwelt by the Holy Spirit when he
comes back there's nothing that is
inconsistent there my my thing here is
that to try to fit these verses to to
try to apply these verses to Muhammad
would be detrimental to Islamic Doctrine
because you have Jesus along with the
father who I know you guys don't believe
Allah is the father um he's saying that
he and the father sin
the Holy Spirit or if in your case
you'll be saying sends Muhammad and
that' be that'll be trouble a poor
understanding of the position first and
foremost
um as I as I mentioned this was not a
preparation for the for for receiving
the Holy Spirit they received the Holy
Spirit he says receive no they
didn't okay so let's let's look at it
um so John 20:22
he breathed on them and said receive the
Holy Spirit if you forgive anyone's sins
their sins are forgiven if you do not
forgive them they are not forgiven so
it's not a preparation he actually said
um receive so they received the Holy
Spirit no where does it say that the
that the that they have the Holy Spirit
at this point now where does it say that
whoa whoa whoa so the term so wait hold
on a second receive doesn't mean so when
Jesus says to them receive the Holy
Spirit he didn't actually give it to
them not at that point he prepared them
for it that's Point all right I'm not
going I'm not going to argue clear words
I'm not I mean it is clear receive the
holy spirit that doesn't necess that
doesn't necessitate that at that moment
they received it but once they were
ready that's when they received the Holy
Spirit what's what's problem nothing I'm
saying is ITC consistent with the text
well no you you just broken the the
English language so that
you no
I I'm not gonna argue okay right it is
clear receive means receive so anyway I
agree
so yes how does this how does this not a
problem for Islamic Doctrine with Jesus
Calling God his father and stuff like
that why it's not a problem for Islamic
Doctrine because Muslims we acknowledge
that there were certain terms that Jews
used prior to Islam and the term father
is one of them now if Jesus referred to
uh Allah as AB
or um
in what we would you know say in the
Arabic language is it a problem for
Muslims no it's not because there was no
strict a Prohibition prior to Islam that
um denies someone from calling God the
father right you know that the Jews
um were calling God the father and they
were referring to themselves as as the
sons of God now why did Islam uh
prohibit this stuff is because of what
the Christians have done with these ter
with this terminology making it
literal making it a relationship of
divinity rather than a relationship
between a close relationship between God
and servant so that's what it is so
islamically we actually have no issue in
saying that there that the Jews prior to
the Advent of Muhammad s alaihi wasallam
would have used these terms like Father
and Son would they have been correct
would they have been correct in using
that term for for God for example in
Islam in the Quran Allah is referred to
as R okay now comes from getting from
someone who's being R for Allah refers
to himself in his relation to us he is
the he is the one
who no the Lord is the R means Lord yeah
let speak man we're back and forth we're
good the you know Lord is a general term
that is being used when it's being
translate the actual term is more in
depth right and it means to be to raise
someone to nurture someone that's what
he actually means okay so this is why to
the father in the
household okay we
say right does it mean he is the lord of
the house or the god of the house no it
means he is the one who nurtures the
household who
raises he does all of this stuff so this
is what it means now and this is the
same sort of terminology that the Jews
would have used in reference to
God okay can I
respond well I don't know what you're
responding to what you just said so
because I I I disagree with your I was
clarifying what I was clarifying to you
why there is a fundamental
misunderstanding yeah I know and I'm
responding to that so what I'm saying is
is that the if you're saying that rub
just simply means one who raises you up
and nurtures you that's actually not
true rub is one with authority
it's it's lordship yeah in Arabic it
means it's lord it's lordship so that's
a totally that's totally different from
Ab which means Father which is why Allah
makes a distinction that he's not a Ab
he's not a father of anyone but he is
your lord and your master right um if
you're talking
about if are you are you teaching me
Arabic now oh I mean we could learn
something from everyone right I'm not
saying that I find super knowable but
you know hear what I had
me question are you teaching me AR if if
this is something that you did not know
then I guess yeah I just taught you
something well I did I do know what the
what the word means and I conin you what
the word actually means in a linguistic
sense so did I
that's all
right no you didn't you told me it means
Lord yeah from a from because of
translations no it's not because of
translation that's literally what the
word means okay name me name me the
dictionary the Arabic dictionary that
denotes that denotes this um you can go
on I think I think you I think you go I
think you can go to like Alam Mani
um that dictionary Alam Mani something
like that yeah that's what I've this
what I've used in the
past heard it's called
man it's a it's an Arabic dictionary and
you put in rub there it'll come up as
Lord Lord Master stuff like that in
English yeah that's what it translates
too and that's what it says the
definition is it uses that as a
definition remember what I said I said
what is the primary definition yeah the
definition immediately comes up is Lord
or Master as a primary definition oh
yeah that's just the first one that
comes up
the first one that that comes up doesn't
make it the def the primary definition I
didn't see it as nurturer or you know
something like that if you looked in the
dictionary that's what he would say as
well I didn't see that maybe maybe if
you can show me that I mean I wouldn't
deny it just you know if I if you could
show me that I learned something
new yeah well I'm eting at the moment so
but you can look it up as well it's very
that's crazy okay so so with this being
said um cuz obviously Allah he said as
in Islam he rejects being called father
and he rejects that because you're
saying that the Christians misused that
when it comes to you know Jesus and
stuff like that started applying deity
to him but they called themselves the
sons of God as well right they call them
as you already said they called
themselves the sons of God and they did
and they meant that you know spirit and
metaphorically like God is their
caretaker that you know he loves them
stuff like that and the Quran rejects
that he rejects even a
metaphorical uh father son relationship
with them so so my question
is yes my question is because I can hear
you saying okay yeah like now in Islam
it's being you know reject it's being
arreated basically before it was all
right my question is was Allah truly
like I know people called him that but
was it the the truth that he was you
know their father in a sense right in
that spiritual or metaphorical sense was
that a true characteristic of him or was
that just something he just
tolerated I I can neither confirm nor
deny this is something from
the and there is nothing in Islamic text
that says that Allah allowed this right
we know that the Jew the children of
Israel did this and I'm saying that the
term is something that Isam would have
would have used because it is in thean
as well this hasn't been abated but in
terms of the uh term and and whatnot
yeah um I can't I can't confirm that
this is a something that God all you
know allowed Once Upon a Time right not
so much allowed because obviously if he
if he tolerated it then it wasn't a sin
per se
right um but I wouldn't say that this
something he he revealed to them to
refer to him as got true so then how can
you say that this would not have been a
problem if Jesus referred to God as his
father if you can't confirm if Allah
allowed that back then or not because we
we are aware of the tradition of the
Jews but that doesn't mean that their
tradition is right that's my point their
tradition could very well be wrong on a
second okay so and the the prophets that
came to their people they would have
been familiar with their language they
would use their language but also
clarify certain things okay so this is
why this is why I'm saying that so you
know the idea okay that
Isa and by the way this is assuming
remember all of this is is under the
assumption that the scripture is
conveying the words of Jesus verbatim
and accurately yeah I'm not going to go
I'm not going to go into the whole
preservation of the text I'm just
assuming it for for for this discussion
um so yeah it's not it's not an issue
this is why even when we speak even when
we speak to Jews and Christians we use
the terms as well we say the father yeah
that's because the the father that's you
know he's the father in their scriptures
my my my point is that um for you to say
that this might this is not a problem
for you as Muslims in Islam if Jesus
were to call god father or some of the
prophets refer to God as father um you
you can't say that it it's not a problem
for Islam when in Islam it is absolutely
atrocious to even you know declare such
a thing that God is is your father in
any way but then say oh well back then
you know because it was in their
tradition it might have been okay
because their tradition could have been
very wrong could have been wrong I
didn't say in Islam I said for the
Muslims it's not an issue in our
saying that there were that people prior
to Islam were referring to Allah as the
father
okay so wait wait so was that right was
that okay for them to do that's my
question he's answer you several times
he's answered you I'm talking to the
host I'm talking to the host may I ask
you a question talking to the host I'm
speaking to the I have a question for
the host you're interrupting the
conversation I have a clarification
question you're you're interrupting the
conversation bro you can I don't want to
speak to you so was that okay for them
to
do yeah I want his name is beyond doubt
theology Beyond doubt theology that's
his that's his app that's it man don't
panic we're bringing up your father so
was that was that ever was that okay for
them to do even though we I I see that
it's recognized it's recognized that
they did this it's recognized that they
did this was it was it was it okay when
they did it is my question
panicking well at the time
yeah well Allah didn't punish them for
it as far as we know yeah you don't you
don't know that you don't know if he
punished him for it or not well that's
what I said as far as we know he didn't
right so look I'm not I'm with um with
Islam is very clear told us something
very clear in terms of understanding the
previous scriptures and the previous
Traditions he said whatever the Quran
affirms you affirm whatever the Quran
denies you deny everything else you
remain agnostic about yeah because you
might confirm things that are false and
you might affirm you know deny things
which are true
so that's my stance I
I I hear what you're saying so so this
is what so this so this is what I would
so this is what I would say I what I
would say to that and I understand the
position you're taking right you're
agnostic on an issue that you know the
Quran doesn't I guess speak of
explicitly right so you don't want to
affirm something that may be false so my
point is is that when you look at all of
what the Quran says what the Hadith
teach you know this idea that Allah is a
father is not okay never was okay you
have no mention of it ever being okay in
the past but all you see is that it's
not okay it's not okay it's not okay so
to give wiggle room that maybe this was
once okay would be I I would say maybe
some level of innovation and you know
like it it has it's not it's not what he
said um and matter of fact like even
chapter 9:30 it says that people called
it says that people called Jesus the son
of the Son of God in the past and said
that they are imitating the disbelievers
of old right so even back then it was
not okay so I was that's why I'm saying
to refer to Allah's father in the text
that's not that's not Islamic that goes
against Islam
actually the Jews and the Christians at
the time of the
Prophet well yes but it's saying that
it's rep they're repeating things that
people before them before the time of
Muhammad was saying so before Islam they
would say these things and you know
refering to referring to Christians who
have um and and other and some Jews who
have attributed the terms Father and Son
a literal sense not to everyone right we
have to remember the Quran doesn't
address The prominent people right the
the majority of of a particular group
Allah subhana addresses everyone
absolutely everyone even people that
didn't even exist at the time okay for
example the atheists Allah subhana
addresses the atheists at the time where
there was no such thing as atheism when
Allah
subhana revealed to to us in the Quran
that um you know have you not seen our
signs in Horizons and within yourselves
what you what what we see at the time it
applies to the people to the people at
the time in terms of pagans the worship
stones and everything like do you not
see the creation do you not see your own
bodies in terms of that but today it's
also applicable to the atheist but they
didn't exist at the time so Allah
subhana T addresses everyone in the past
present and future right including the
Christians so for example when Allah
says right do not say three is he you
know you have Christians that assume
it's referring to the Trinity no it's
not it's a it's it's uh addressing any
formulation of any Triad or Trinity or
three individuals you know because there
were several uh different beliefs
throughout history when Allah subhana
says in the Quran did you uh referring
to the day of judgment and him question
in Isa saying did you tell the people to
to worship yourself and your mother as
Gods besides me is he talking about the
Trinity no is he talking about
Protestants no he's talking about
Catholics he's talking about cians and
anyone else who would have venerated
Mary okay so you know Allah subhana tala
in his wisdom in his full knowledge he
addresses absolutely everyone in the
Quran no one is left out
whatsoever so so in light of all of this
this is what I was saying leading
leading back to this if we're going to
be if you're going to try to plug in
Muhammad into the paraclet versus it's
it's
detrimental I I know you're saying
you're not you're saying some Muslims do
so for the Muslims that do I'm saying
that it's detrimental to for them
contextually and it's detrimental for
them islamically because if they're
doing that they would have to be
affirming uh the deity of Christ the
sunship of Christ and how he along with
the father is sending
the Holy Spirit or in their case
Muhammad so Jesus and the father or
Jesus and Allah both send Muhammad
together and uh and then Muhammad comes
out of out of can I speak for a second
can I speak for a second yes first and
foremost uh just another reminder
another day another reminder that people
like the person underneath me are not
worthy here we GOI goe goe and kick me
why are you guys coming to cry man stop
coming to cry what is the Panic
here Mohammad knows who I am man he's
not he's having a conversation stop
crying I'm Not Gon to say anything you
won't like trust me I'm G to say
something you really like so so listen
I'm G I'm telling you right now y uh Rel
religiously and jally we're not supposed
to be having dignified conversations
with somebody who co-signs the
desecration of the white Act oh my God
logic
[Music]